Look right into the cameras at the fun to do or what did you do?
Or it'll give me...
Yeah.
Okay, today is March 7th, 2017, and we were Stephen Strauss's distinguished professor of
Force Technology OSU, and we will talk to him a very amount about his career and his time at OSU
I'd like to begin by building more of a biographical sketch of your life and ask you where we were.
I was born in Brooklyn, New York.
Is that where you grew up?
I was there until I was 16, and I've got for college at that point, and never went back.
There's really a bunch of various schools and places of employment, but not back then since I started college.
Tell me about the Brooklyn of your childhood.
Well, you know, I had a very simple upbringing.
You know, my parents did not have a lot of money, and they also had a fourth child.
And at the time they got to me, they were sort of done being a careful caretakers,
so I really had my run of the streets as it were.
I traveled around New York City on the subways, and buses extensively.
And pretty much called the shots came to one, as I wanted to, so I was a bit of a feral kid.
So that was fun.
Tell me a bit about your parents and your family background.
Yeah, my father was a postal worker, second half of his life, and worked evenings,
and enjoyed his job a great deal.
He had a great network of friends, and I think he enjoyed being there,
and more than he enjoyed being home with the kids, with my mom.
My mom was a hard worker, but she was set up over a wound,
I think, by the depression and raising children,
was sort of mentally run out, let's say, with the time she got to me.
So, you know, very humble, simple upbringing.
You know, parents had good values, and still didn't need, you know,
ten times over the value of getting an education,
making yourself better, and helped me all along the way,
once they realized I had good academic potential.
They kept finding money, they didn't think they had to keep my academic career going.
So, solid upbringing, but also not a great deal of mentoring,
advice meant, you know, any of those things that I hope I've given to my kids,
having a better situation.
Can you tell me a bit more about community life in the specific neighborhood
that you were in, what neighborhood was that?
It was neighborhood called Barrel Park in New York.
It was roughly 350 between quiet religious Jews,
many of the Pacific, and, you know, dressed in all the garb,
and refusing to associate really with what you might call mainstream society.
And then Italians, and many of those were Sicilians who were first,
or one and a half generations off the boat,
and they were rough and tough and tumble,
and hated Jews as much as they'd used hated them.
And I grew up with most of my friends, who I had a secular type of life,
my parents were Jewish, but very reformed,
and nothing like the cacetic Jews,
I was something of an in-betweener,
where I played with these kids, that was out in the street,
playing stick ball and football and, you know,
just with Italian friends who didn't know what to make of me.
Because they were taught to hate Jews, and I was a Jew,
but not really a Jew, because I wasn't like those guys,
and so it was a strange upbringing in that regard.
But some of these Italian friends are still very close to me,
even at the stage of my life, and so it was, you know,
they were struggling with many of them,
but we're getting brutalized at home.
I mean, that was normal for this Sicily,
and culture they came from.
They came in the five minutes late, and they were getting beaten.
And I had a very different kind of upbringing.
So it was quite amazing to see that,
see the set of Jews, see my in-betweener kind of,
growing up, and figured out from there.
What were you interested in as a boy growing up?
Well, you know, the big, I was interested in sports.
I was just a very active sporty kid.
I still run, I referee soccer, I still,
you know, I follow some of the OSU teams.
So I'm still a sporty guy, so these Italians are very athletic,
and so that was a real connection.
And then probably the big change was, you know,
it's got two teenage years,
and I started, I met friends who were somewhat
politically active in protesting, being on war,
and being interested in recreational marijuana,
and things that were very common in the generation back then.
So I really, I moved away from these Italian kids,
I moved further away after my apartments,
I did get that done because I felt like the family needed me
to do that.
And then I moved away from Judaism,
moved away from these Italian more rough elements
and found a group of friends that, you know,
were more intelligent.
They were mixed of Jews and Gentiles,
but more, you would say, progressive or left-leaning.
And I grew my hair along, I had beads,
and junior high school, I remember that started,
and became, you know, fairly politically active,
one to a bunch of demonstrations as a high schooler
and then a college.
At what point did science became,
kind of something was important to you.
Yeah, you know, I had, I went to a high school
in Brooklyn called Brooklyn Tech.
So in New York City there's three selective public high schools.
And Brooklyn Tech is one of the three,
where there's an entrance exam.
And it was, it's really a place for training engineers,
and in the old school engineers,
were people who just shut up and calculated.
And the teaching of science was rough,
and for people who were gifted and mathematics,
I guess it was okay,
but I was completely turned off to science.
I wanted no part of it.
All the teachers, the old education system,
was the opposite of sort of my somewhat progressive interest.
So when I saw, I graduated,
I did take the engineering classes,
I had to at Brooklyn Tech and did fine.
And then when I got to college, I went to the state university in New York
of purchase, which is sort of an alternative arm of the state university
system in New York.
Didn't have grades, had all kinds of experimental teaching systems.
I majored in philosophy for a year,
or just trying to figure out what I was interested in and so for it.
And really, because I was interested in the environment,
and with the saved the world,
and I didn't see how a degree in philosophy
was going to really help me do that.
And I was concerned about my economics,
the ability to survive.
So I switched to biology at that point,
and do the interest in the environment,
and some kind of a job.
And then I got into the science track.
I was also, I had skipped a grade in middle school,
junior high school as we called it.
I was born at the end of the year.
So I was almost two years in mature compared to a lot of my peers.
And I was really confused in college.
So I was going through these transitions,
of the environment, science, and just using a lot of marijuana
and other things.
And I was just so finalized at time out,
after a year off.
And that was a really smart thing to do.
And worked, saved money, did some great travel
and went to Alaska with friends and other things.
And then when I went back,
I was able to transfer to Cornell
and become a serious science student in Cornell.
Very, very rigorous.
And so really, from then till now,
I've just been busted my ass, if you will.
Trying to keep up with the incredible pace and demands
of being a scientist.
That's interesting.
I was going to ask about how a kid
from Brooklyn becomes somebody who spends his career in the forest,
and it sounds like it.
It emerged out of this political impulse.
Political impulse.
And along with that, I began to backpap some
with some friends.
And when you think about the fires,
I remember being very curious, you know,
what's this tree?
You know, who knows?
What does it do?
And so I got curious about it.
I love the outdoors.
There was an element of use of drugs in there
that made me sort of just worship in a religious sense.
I went in some experience with friends
that were just, you know,
I still think of this day, these friends
of ours.
Friends of mine, you know,
talk about how magical it was
to see the environment,
love the environment,
the reality out there,
bond, try to understand it,
try to think about being a caretaker of the environment.
And so it was inspirational.
It was what I was, you know,
that was all that confusion of the youth
and the feeling of the need to save the environment.
And then with sort of recreational use of some drugs
in the comradeship,
I just became passionate about it.
So I don't want to overemphasize
the drug part,
except that it gave a great sense of joy
and sort of sharing that,
you know,
what would have happened anyway,
but maybe it was more intense.
Yeah.
How did you select Cornell,
or did Cornell select you?
Well, I selected Cornell,
you know,
with my limited knowledge base
growing up in Brooklyn
and my parents, you know,
working class,
neither one of them had a college education.
You know,
we just assumed the next thing you do
is go to Brooklyn College or some
very affordable nearby place
because you couldn't possibly afford
to go to town school,
let alone Cornell.
And my sister was sort of five years ahead
of me and she said if it broke
in the thinking shackles
that, you know,
we could do better
that we could reach higher
and she encouraged me to apply.
And one thing nice about Cornell is very selective,
but there's also,
it's a hybrid really
between a state-supported university
and a private university.
And biology is actually split.
I think it still is there.
So if you get into biology
and you're a resident of the state
in New York,
your tuition is about half.
So it made it suddenly affordable
whereas it wouldn't have been otherwise.
And then I started getting a bunch of scholarships
because I really worked hard
and got very good grades.
And then, like I said,
then my father realized
that it was getting a ease of Cornell
who was this kid.
He started just paying off debts and stuff.
And sounds like this is an important
moment in your life Cornell.
Yeah.
It was the start of,
you know, a whole new person,
you know,
wasn't this kid in Brooklyn,
but was someone who was going somewhere.
And, you know,
I started working with an ecologist at Cornell.
It's also taking all these courses
and biology and evolution
that, you know, blow your mind,
and suddenly you're thinking about
all this big, big stuff
and also thinking about saving the world.
And, you know,
I still never saw myself as a professor
or a scientist.
I was really unable to do that.
But, you know,
I'd get a degree
and then I think, well,
great.
I have a bachelor's now.
What do I do with it?
And the world of biology
you are a technician for somebody.
And then you think about,
well, I'd get a master's
and it's really the same thing.
And sort of really be a scientist
to be somebody who calls the shots
who's thoughts and intellect and ideas
or what drives,
what happens.
You need to in science.
You need to move on.
You need to be on.
You need to get post up.
So I just never got off the train
because I realized
I needed to stay on it,
though I never imagined myself
being a scientist
with my humble upbringing.
So it just kept going.
I kept having success
and then from
Cornell,
I got into the Yale School of Forestry
and Environment,
which is another nap today.
It's much more a
breeding ground for environmental activists
and policy people.
So it's a fully transition.
And then I went to Cal Workway
after that,
which is similar.
And so I kept getting into
this very challenging,
very great academic
environments that were even more
and more environmentally
as well as scientific
and players on the world scene.
How did you arrive at Forest Sciences?
Something you wanted to focus on
from biology and
sort of an entry to you developing
a scientific foundation,
but then you focused your
perspective a little bit from there.
Yeah, it's a really interesting question.
I think it was the fusion
of backpacking and being
out in the environment.
I also remember when I was,
I think, 17,
I hitchhiked out
from the East Coast to the West Coast.
And I was in our
again,
just as a long hair kid by myself.
And I remember getting
out a ride with a
longer.
I was up in the Oregon
Cascade somewhere near
Salem.
Not really know what I was doing.
This isn't me.
And I thought I was going
to back back to the
Cypher Crest,
to start back backing it.
It was all under snow.
And you know,
I just didn't really know what I was
doing.
But I had this conversation with
this longer.
And I sort of told them about
all the things I've read
from the Sierra Club that
helped that
shower forest view was.
And the Northwest.
And how a clear cut
is a sin that should never happen.
And he just said,
Now,
let me tell you what we do.
Let me tell you what the
safeguards are.
And I had no idea how one
sighted and biased
perspective I was getting
from the Sierra Club.
And that issue actually
continues to this day.
As I work in biotechnology,
where you have the
organizations that I trusted
has been truthful
and telling the whole story,
I know I realize
do not.
And so that's one of the steps
in my evolution from
save the world,
simple science,
science will save the world
to the real politics
and the real information
society where
and of course,
has exploded of light
with all the fake news
and everything.
But that's been going on
forever to one degree or not.
It's just not a presidential
but we're quite so blatantly.
But anyway,
that really opened my eyes
got me interested.
So what is really happening
in far straight?
And why do you clear it?
And we can do it safely.
And can you use
intensive technologies
of all sorts,
you know,
conscientiously responsibly
amidst all the noise.
And so that's a place
that you tested a work
in for 30 years
and OSU in the biotech
controversy area,
related to trees
and agriculture in general.
Back to Yale,
okay,
Fest today was
surprised to find out
that they had a four
sites program.
Yeah,
yeah.
Tell me about that
environment for you.
Yeah,
Yale was a,
I went there
first
because when I was a Cornell
and I was
interning
undergraduate research
with a ecologist.
And he was
grooming me to go work
with his PhD supervisor,
brilliant manning,
her movement
an ecosystem
biologist.
And I was all set to go there.
And then my graduation
was
delayed a year
because I had
overlooked a requirement
in my advisor.
And so I had one more year
to kind of figure out who I was.
And I took a class
in far straight.
I just got a little more interested
in sort of application
in the near return sense.
And so I got to
Yale
to work to the ecosystem
ecologists and training
work with her,
but I did work with her
of warm and sun.
But I sort of
fear off and became more of a
physiologist
practitioner as compared to
an ecosystem ecologist.
But I also discovered
that Yale was a place
where the number of
sort of scientists
taking the number of
practitioner type scientists
is very small.
I mean,
it had really transitioned
60s and 70s
into a training ground
for
environmental activists,
environmental lawyers,
you know,
a lot of people
apocalyptic,
a lot of international organizations
come through a place
as like Yale
and Duke
Forestry is done
a similar thing.
Cal Berkeley
Forestry is done a similar thing.
We're
really to
survive
and be a
college
in those institutions
that are not
parents.
Or if they are,
they're mostly not
in Berkeley's case,
they're kind of a split one.
They really had to become
really working on
big issues of
environmental science and
global sense,
so they transition.
And there's
still some science there
in all these places,
but it's relatively small,
or it's highly
environmental.
And so it's,
you know,
in Oregon state still
we have a lot of
that too,
but we also have a much bigger
because we serve
where in this region
with this incredible forest
forestry sector,
whereas New Haven
is not in such a region anymore.
There's still a little bit
of forestry,
but very, very little
by comparison.
And so we here
try to serve both,
you know,
training students
to work in the industry,
work in the land management
agencies very actively,
as well as do science
and being the cutting edge
of the environmental issues.
So anyway,
but being at Yale
was very much a step into that world,
which is a world
I wanted to be in my whole life,
but I also realized that
I was a little naive,
maybe,
thinking that science
had more of the answers.
And in reality,
I've found the science
has a lot of answers,
but mostly the laws
and social perceptions
make it difficult
to have those answers
to be used
particularly in the genetics,
which we can talk about at some point.
Yeah.
What was your research focus
at that point?
Yeah.
So at Yale,
I did,
I think, two or three projects
there were also.
Yale doesn't have a
master's thesis requirement,
so I got involved in research projects.
I went out to the US Forest Service in California,
in Berkeley,
actually when I had the Pacific Southwest Station,
I worked with scientists there.
And got my first paper,
was on the inheritance,
so pines have these turcanized.
They make them smell sunrise
and the resin that comes down
and tries to protect them from bark,
beas and so forth.
Well, the chemistry of that
rate, that resin varies widely.
And so sometimes you have one chemical,
sometimes another,
it's important to the ecology and the organism.
So I figured out how it's inherited
some scientists before me,
both French feel,
but very, very, very man,
had made these hybrids
between different species
and the progeny,
then had high alpha pining,
low alpha pining,
mercy and all these chemicals.
So he said,
did this basic,
meeting work,
crossing species of different industries
that, and then you could map the genes
in the project.
So he basically said,
here's the project,
you want to map the genes.
And so I went out and
measured them, you know,
with help of the scientists,
and that was my first paper.
And then there were a couple of other small projects
like that.
So really,
what it was,
it was very much being an apprentice
and science is like that a lot,
where, you know,
people do projects over many years
and then students and postdocs come in
and sort of figure it out
and add value to it,
tweak it,
and take it with trees,
but you know, science in general,
or, you know,
experiments take years to decades.
And so I came into the stream of science
that, yeah,
far assigned,
the far service scientists
were doing in Berkeley,
and was able to publish
and papers,
and that set a set me up
for, you know,
getting into grad school,
and talent,
and success from there on.
Was that your first exposure
to the tree genetics?
I mean, it's obviously,
yeah, really.
Yeah, when I went to Yale,
it was not,
as I told you, it was the ecosystem scientist.
And I started working for a geneticist there
that put me on a couple of projects,
and then he set up this opportunity
with a far service
in Berkeley,
California,
and name is Tom Lighting.
He passed away from cancer
a couple of years ago,
but very, very, very well known
internationally.
And so he,
and he was at Yale,
and then he moved to the far service,
and so they set up those opportunities.
So I went to Yale,
you know,
I don't particularly registered in genetics.
I was open to it,
and then the opportunities,
the people.
And then I went to Berkeley too,
you know,
that was partly to work with Tom Lighting,
but I still was open to being a physiologist,
a silvicultrist,
managing forest,
and a larger scale,
made the oncologist even
of some kind,
and then again,
opportunities,
the far service there.
Also one other theme in all this
is one thing that's frustrating me
about ecology,
and it still does a lot,
is it's hard to measure things precisely.
You know,
it's,
and to somebody,
a lot of scientists,
they want to get to the bottom of things.
They don't want to have a conclusion.
That says,
well,
to this community that can be this,
we have data,
we have models,
you know,
what's this way,
and that's just an nature of the beast.
And in genetics,
you tend to get much closer to hard answers.
And that was appealing to me.
And then all the genetic technology
that was coming along,
continues to just,
you know,
my whole career,
the field of genetics,
is exploded five times,
was attractive,
you know,
so it was enzymes,
and it's first was Turkinoids,
and the chemistry thereof,
and the gas chromatographs,
and that was these enzymes
who were doing for look at genetic variation,
in a way that we never did,
and then it was DNA,
and then it was genomics,
so doing DNA on massive scale,
and then genetic engineering,
so that it's been this progression
that would incredibly powerful,
and intellectually exciting,
and potentially very important technologies.
So that's also pulled me out of ecology,
something.
These technologies,
and I've been using ecology quite a lot,
but it's taken a long time to get there.
Sounds like it was a fairly seamless transition
to Berkeley for you.
Well, yeah, you know, I've been there before,
and you know, I knew the place,
and I loved it.
You know, I just loved being in Berkeley,
those five years I was there.
I was, you know,
it's a great environment for a young person,
and definitely a very,
artificial environment.
And the reason I say that,
as I want to,
one of my memories from there,
is I think the first year we were there,
so this would be 1980,
I hope I have the story right.
Reagan was running against,
I think it was Jenny Carter,
maybe for Carter's second term or something like that,
and it could be in Berkeley
and think that Carter was a shoe in.
And of course,
I think he won no state,
but Massachusetts or something like that.
And, you know,
so again, you're in this little bubble of Berkeley,
and you know, everything's very progressive,
you know, realize where the country is at,
as the police said,
it's sort of a little bit of this last election.
Yeah.
Tell me a bit more about this time,
you progressed through your PhD years.
Yeah.
The, you know,
the PhD in Berkeley,
it was really a good format,
really enjoyed Cal Berkeley a lot.
It had a lot of sort of what I was mentioning about,
yeah, the environmental stuff,
the foam and the science,
and also had a lot,
still a lot of the traditional stuff,
some of the older economists
and civil cultures,
very, very famous people,
and Fox Johnson,
my main mentor at Berkeley,
Billy,
very charismatic guy,
very much,
really in the mold that I've taken on a micro,
I've kind of been a,
a spokesperson,
if you will,
for the use of genetic engineering,
as a technology in far strip,
which is difficult thing.
It's difficult,
biologically,
it's difficult,
socially,
a lot of the incredible power of environmental groups,
around the world,
that's exploded during my life.
They're almost all opposed to either unilaterally,
or extremely negative.
So, Bill was kind of,
he was a,
a proponent of cloning in far strip.
So, you know,
you got to a wild forest now,
every tree is a unique genotype,
like humans,
mostly are,
with the exception of the occasional identical twin.
And he said,
well,
what if you could pick the very most productive one,
out of this mass evaluation,
you know,
not just one,
but the top,
the top ten,
the top hundred for production purposes.
For wild forest,
you'll maintain all the diversity you possibly can,
but for production forests.
If we could clone it,
the benefits would be ploned,
and the benefits would be used.
And so,
he argued that his whole career,
and had some success.
I mean,
some of it was used,
but he was very much pushing against the tie to that point,
that the industry was very traditional,
and then the environmental tie as well.
So, I've said it,
in a sense,
followed in its footsteps,
which is interesting,
you know,
just I think,
but being also outspoken on some of these policy issues,
and using sort of innovative,
new,
socially,
novel,
genetic technology.
Me and the GMO area,
in the,
the Conan area.
So, anyway,
you know,
he's a very outspoken guy,
and so he's very influential to me.
And,
but the whole,
intellectual environment of Berkway was very stimulating,
like,
TA in forest policy.
So, you know,
as a young scientist,
among most scientists,
I would say,
have a limited notion of what how policies are made,
and how laws are passed,
and what they mean.
They just figure,
you know,
you learn how it works in nature,
and then you do it smarter and better.
And the notion that there's all these layers of roles,
and rigs,
and perceptions,
invested interests,
you know,
we're just kind of naive,
I mean,
it's just that simple.
And so,
being at Berkway was a time,
my eyes opened up,
you know,
taking and teaching about forest policy,
realize that,
you know,
if scientists really want to change the world,
they really need to be out there.
They can't be naive in their labs,
in their little fields,
they have to be out there interacting with society.
And,
you know,
I think I've done some of that,
not as much as some of my colleagues,
but,
you know,
and I think today,
you see a lot of activity on campuses,
and that scientists need to do it even more.
I mean,
I have this March on Science,
March 4 science coming up,
in April,
and I think it's scientists saying,
you know,
it's just not going to be okay to be quiet.
You have to get out there.
And,
but speaking for scientists,
also,
I'm rambling around it,
but speaking for science,
is also really complicated.
The scientists are all biased and ideological,
like everybody else,
so it's a really messy thing.
Your dissertation was,
uninstallage and exercise,
that correct?
It was,
back on those days,
they had these enzyme technologies,
called isosines,
or alasines,
so it turns out that,
you know,
you have thousands of proteins in your body,
trees do too,
and do the genetic variation,
the forms of those proteins vary.
They just do what they do,
but they do it a little bit different way.
And so,
back in the 60s,
70s, 80s scientists realize that,
instead of measuring genetic variation,
say based on variation,
and height of people like ourselves,
that are influenced by the environment,
how will you,
as well as your DNA,
you could look right at the products of DNA,
these proteins.
We weren't able to look at DNA itself yet,
so that whole alasine,
genetic diversity,
technology was very,
very big for 30 years,
and that's my thesis about trying to see,
if you could look at the amount of
genetic polymorphism,
variability in these enzymes,
and trees,
and could predict their productivity,
our trees that have a greater diversity of enzymes,
of a more productive and a natural environment.
Using them materials are available to me.
That was the question that I tried to answer,
and I had some success in the sense
that I got some applications out about it,
and good journals,
but by no means that I resolve it at that level.
Now,
that question actually,
a bigger question in science,
still continues.
So you finished up at Calen 1985,
and then you arrived at OSU,
how did that come about?
That was an amazing thing,
so I did this thesis that was really about
genetic polymorphism,
whether it predicts productivity,
and environmental stress tolerance,
was another element of it,
and it had experimental plantations,
but it wasn't really about production,
and it wasn't about biotechnology,
and any means that wasn't called biotechnology,
we didn't have that word really back then.
And at the time,
in the 80s,
and I was at Cal,
the field of biotechnology,
so we're committed DNA,
cutting and splicing genes,
was starting.
It started in bacteria a few years earlier,
and scientists were beginning to use it.
Study disease is to study cancer,
to study human pathogens of various sorts,
and then it started percolating and percolating into plants,
or people using it the same way.
And then scientists figured out
how they could transfer genes from one organism to another,
so they could do sort of what people had done in bacteria years earlier,
they could now do an implant
to the possibility of genetic engineering plants
for enhanced traits suddenly was there,
and everybody was talking about it.
And I remember,
I think it was 84 year before I graduated,
my mentor Tom Ledig,
and I mentioned from Yale,
I went to Berkeley,
held a big conference about how should we,
how should we be using biotechnologies in forestry,
what are the opportunities,
what are the constraints,
and I'm watching this,
and I'm not a biotechnologist,
I didn't really know what DNA was per se,
apart from,
and suddenly it's like this is the next big thing.
It's coming at us,
and then the year 84,
85,
depending on exactly how you dated,
the first genetic engineer plant was created,
and then two years later,
the first job of the engineer tree,
a poverty tree,
that I've actually continued to work on,
most of them,
my career was created,
and far as service is working on it,
just seeing like this is just a big,
a big, wonderful thing,
and a big scientific technological challenge.
And so I remember when this job came open,
at Oregon State,
I was,
you know,
somewhere around December,
or so,
before,
maybe January of 85,
and I remember seeing it,
someone pointed out to me,
you know,
so we've always had Oregon State,
we've always had really strong forest genetics,
sort of a subdiscipline of forest science,
and we've been strong in,
at OSU,
we've been strong in the forest service,
right across the parking lot,
and so we had a geneticist,
Kim Chang,
who was retiring,
and so they said,
well,
what should we do?
Should we hire another Kim Chang,
or a gene meaning chromosome level,
genetic biology of trees,
Douglas Far,
or should we start going down deeper,
just go down to the DNA level,
that's where the science is going,
that's all this,
all this foaming going on,
and so we said,
we're gonna take over,
we're asking higher biotechnology,
and I don't think any other far,
as we school had done so yet.
But,
at that time,
there were two or three that did it,
so I don't remember if it was us,
or in the sea state,
or who was actually number one,
we were right there,
instead of taking this risk really,
to invest in this new area.
And so at that point,
there,
there were not a cadre of farce biotechnology,
PhDs and postdocs around,
because if you don't even exist,
there were a couple,
just starting who had done work,
and other species,
barley,
a colleague of mine,
Daniel,
and I want you to grab very great scientists,
had done a postdoc,
and barley learning some of that stuff,
but it wasn't trees,
these are some of my competitors,
and for this job.
Anyway, so I asked my mentors,
I just said,
what's with this biotechnology thing?
Is this like,
flash in the pan?
Is it, you know,
should I apply for this job?
I don't have back,
and I said,
yeah, you should apply it for it.
You're as qualified as anybody,
getting how young this field is,
and then I went on this crash course
of learning about biotechnology.
And so I applied,
and they basically hired me on the notion
that I had potential to grow with the field,
and, you know,
I would say,
I would expect that turned out to be a pretty good,
pretty good guess.
And so,
that's how it started.
I really,
this is really a new venture for me.
It was a new venture for
far straight LSU,
and, you know,
it's had a number of turns that,
no one predicted,
but it's,
from a science point of view,
from a career,
development point of view,
it's, you know,
been a very successful.
Yeah.
So it was like a nice piece of
strategic thing here,
a visionary thing here.
I think so.
Yeah, I think they knew they were doing that.
They didn't want to know where it was going to go,
and I got here,
you know,
I said,
so what are you going to do?
I said, I don't know.
Well, what's by your technology,
figure it out,
and do it.
And actually the first five,
seven years,
I realized that
genetic engineering was not really,
you know,
it had been done once,
in one place,
a tree was engineered,
but it wasn't ready to go.
So what can I do,
and what I realized I could do,
and I was also a very successful,
and made a name for myself,
early as I could use these DNA techniques,
and I think you're out,
the evolution of some of our major tree species.
I think I had the most important paper at that time,
on pines and how they evolved.
I had the most important paper at that time,
on Douglas Farr,
and its relatives,
and where it came from,
and the relationship to all its relatives
around the Pacific,
around and beyond.
So there's a lot of insights that,
you know,
when you get to the DNA level,
when you get an insight about
relationships and evolution,
they're often very,
very strong.
For a decision,
you get when you sequence or analyze DNA
to that level,
suddenly people say,
well,
it's not just his opinion about
whether the size of the cones,
of the effectiveness of the bars,
the most important trait,
it's this,
you know, sort of random look at the DNA,
and it's just shelves at you,
which trees are most related to which,
who the common ancestor is,
and so,
what I did the first five or seven years,
I did a lot of this,
genetic evolutionary analysis,
and it's a really high quality science,
and the people at OSU,
my idea in the department,
I would have luck to see me,
like help the forest industry,
right in and out,
and I said,
this is the right thing to be doing right now.
And so,
you know,
they didn't have a very open mind about it.
But then eventually,
and perhaps I'm getting ahead of myself,
but I'll mention briefly,
what happened in Oregon and in Northwest is,
people started worrying about
sources of wood and pulp,
because we had to spot it out of the war,
as we had rising environmentalism,
and people were afraid that wooden DNA would,
so they started investing in the Department of Energy,
made major investments in growing these
popular trees and plantations,
like the ones along I-84,
that we talked about.
Those are products of that,
and so people started doing serious research,
and that was a big project
that University of Washington on that,
and I realized that I had the expertise
that was developed to add a genetic engineering element to it.
And that started early 90s,
late 80s, early 90s,
and I started working with the industries
and developed an industry cooperative,
consortium, basically a public private partnership,
and our College of Forestry has a bunch of those,
and still does,
where they provide money.
Not a lot of money,
but enough to sort of help guide it
toward things of interest to them,
and then we at the University of Utah,
use our resources,
and go out and go grant dollars
to sort of make good science of relevance happen.
And working in Poplar,
as I mentioned,
our industry that was engineering was a popular,
suddenly people are thinking about growing
Poplar's on a major scale,
and Oregon in the Northwest.
Let's use this technology to do it even better.
And so a lot of my career has been said,
if I took that step,
for I'm this consortium,
started working on Poplar's in genetic engineering,
and I quickly got involved
in some of the social and legal issues
on it, like I said earlier,
those are big,
and they've continued to be big.
So that was the reason I made that shift
early in my career at OSU,
into genetic engineering per se,
and also helping to deal with
the social elements,
working with industries,
forest industries, biotech industries,
and so that's been kind of the big middle
of my career in self-contentures.
What is it about Poplar's,
and I think much attracted to this work?
You know,
they're much better from a science point of view,
they're much better model organisms.
So everything about Douglas Farr and Pine,
you can imagine
when it comes to doing genetic manipulation as hard.
Those turpentines,
I mentioned early,
well, they mess up your getting your DNA
out and analyzing it.
People have sort of gotten it out over at these days,
but it's just one other thing.
The genomes are huge.
In Poplar's,
we figured out pretty early on,
the number one tree,
how to insert a gene,
or modify a gene,
and then grow the progeny
and see how that one gene affects them.
And in the coniferous,
that's still incredibly difficult to do,
very expensive and very difficult.
So something about them makes them easier
to engineer,
their genomes are small,
they grow faster.
It's very powerful in genetics.
When you make a genetic change,
or you have a genetic variant of interest,
to make copies of it.
Just for replications,
so you have high quality science,
poplar's,
and nature,
cloned themselves all the time.
That's, you know,
these asspins you may have read about,
these grows of asspins.
They're kinds of poplar's,
can cover many many acres in one single genotype.
That doesn't happen much in coniferous.
So they're easier to make copies of.
So there's a bunch of reasons,
easy to transform,
small genome,
easy to make copies of faster growing.
That makes them very good genetic models.
And then also,
you know,
the industry was already looking at making hybrids,
between different species,
to increase productivity.
They were already cloning them for plantations.
And so the genetics was very intense.
And then adding genetic engineering,
as another kind of genetics made sense,
because the industry had already brought it in science.
It's already brought it to this level.
Let's take that level further.
When you look at,
Douglas,
or our pines,
even today,
the genetics is primitive,
you know,
compared to any crop species,
compared to poplar's.
And so it's not prior to sage,
genetic engineering is what we need to do now.
We're still sitting in the neolithic with breeding.
So it doesn't make as much sense.
The compost it does.
So you have all these reasons,
the biology as well as the state of breeding.
And then also,
if you're making a particular product with
poplar's like pulp,
or particular kinds of wood or biofuels,
you can optimize it much more.
And that's how the industry came about,
whereas in this sort of generalized forestry,
we're making all kinds of things,
and they're all kinds of conditions.
We don't control the environment as much
as they grow on it.
You know, steep hillsides,
and poppers,
it's more agricultural.
In fact, they're regulated as agricultural crops,
by Oregon and Washington.
And so everything about the social and biological environment
made it sensible to consider trying to add
in genetic engineering as an exgenetic technology.
Yeah.
Backing up,
just a hair.
I mean,
just to be collecting a little bit of institutional knowledge about that.
Yeah.
I've been in diversity of college.
Well, what do you remember about your early impressions of OSU
and of the College of Forestry?
You know,
the things I've stand out over all these years,
Dean Stomberg, who hired me,
and successor George Brown,
just as an incredible sense of,
you know,
go out there and make an impact.
Serve the state,
the nation's serve, just this incredible ethic of service.
You know, I came out of, I came in here still somewhat young,
still very much wanting to do science and wanting to survive also in academia.
I was very nervous, you know, I was going to be able to get tenure and, you know,
and I just, and they really wanted much more.
They weren't interested so much, I'm going to survive and get my own grand,
but what am I going to do to change the world for the better?
Well, how am I going to, and also they had a sense of how am I going to serve?
The Oregon industry, they're, and they're, again, more productive and economic and more vital.
So I just felt that, and I felt the pressure of it,
but I also felt that it was wholesome and real and good.
And so that was another reason for the transition to poplers.
I, I mentioned, I did this genetic work early on in the evolutionary relationships at different species.
That was a great way to use biotech methods to advance science,
but it wasn't really going to advance Oregon farce.
Right, and except in a very fundamental level.
And so when poplers came along, and the fact that I could use genetic engineering,
I could do great science, and it can have an impact on the industry and on society, maybe tomorrow.
If we can really grow trees, you know, 10%, 20% better by using genetic engineering methods,
and we can do it in poplers in my lab and get it out there, you know, that's exciting.
That a conjunction of application, and, you know, one thing that we've worked on two
for many years that tied into my environmental background is, you know, it was pretty obvious to me,
that generic engineering trees, poplers, we're going to be controversial for our different species.
We've already seen an agriculture in medicine, and so it's not like society is going to just say,
Rara, Rara, Rara, let's have more of it.
They're going to say, I don't like this, or they're going to say, who controls it,
and so on and so forth.
And how should we regulate it?
What should the role of a EPA being, and should we really have very strict regulations?
So I, you know, it was obvious to me that was all going to happen, and what's happening, and the
the biggest issue that science can deal with about that is, so release of propagules into
natural environments.
So I think cognitively you cross a line when you say we're going to genically engineer something.
Then you're really saying that humans are really taking control of this organism and changing
into their needs.
Of course, we do that with conventional breeding, and all of our crops, corn, whatever it is,
are looking at something like their wild relatives, and we've made that cognitively,
but I think now we're even more conscious of that than we used to be.
Genic engineering, because it's a, you know, unnatural, mostly unnatural technique.
It does happen in nature, but not commonly, you cross this cognitive line where it was,
obviously, just to me, that people are not going to, well, people might say, well, I accept
in these intensive popular plantations that look nothing like unnatural, that genic engineering
can have a place, but I don't want that pollen and seeds spreading out into wild, riparian
cotton would areas where really what we value is by our diversity and all the ecosystem functions.
That's going to be a problem, and indeed it is, so we said, you know, so we need to,
for those plantation trees, we need to shut down flowering.
We think trees will grow faster as a result, but the main thing is that even though poppers
do a vegetarian, we spread a little bit, we can manage that, you know, but we can't manage
pollen floating, you know, miles and miles in there. And so another exciting thing was, in addition
to developing the gene transfer methods and working with industries to test things,
we said, we're going to develop the genetic containment technology,
so society accepts it. And we continue to make that our focus all these years,
and that really tied into my sort of environmental consciousness coming in.
Let's use advanced technology, but let's do it right. And so that's, you know, that's probably
what I'm most known for around the world is developing this containment technology,
and putting it into practice. To test a long time, you know, the science things are wild,
getting the genes in, and then if you're studying flowering, you have to wait years,
because trees don't flower right away. So it really is. I didn't realize it so much at the time,
when I made that decision in the early 90s, I was committing to two or three decades of experiments,
and that's what's happened. You know, they're still going on, they're still on the field,
outside, we're out. So at what point did you start to receive some pushback from various
outside entities? Was that pretty much from the get-go? You know, in the beginning,
there really has been, and I don't know that anybody's measured it, I'm sure actually,
that's what they haven't measured it. I should probably go find the papers that they've done it,
but I used to mock some of the media coverage, and including how us use own public relations,
that here's biotechnology, it's to answer to all our problems. It's going to feed the world,
it's going to, you know, rat revolutionize, we're going to make square trees that, you know,
just go right into the boards, you know, it's all this crazy stuff that I knew was not going to
have, they're not going to happen in my lifetime, so it was hot. And society kind of, that's where
they were sitting giddy about it, and then over, I think it was the late 90s when various things
happened, and agricultural biotechnology, where then the media coverage became pretty negative,
and big environmental groups, like Greenpeace, with, you know, hundreds of millions of dollars,
funds, essentially environmental corporations decided they were against all of it everywhere,
whether you were making, you know, a vitamin A to deal with blindness, whether you're trying
to make sure they're against all of it, it was an ideological thing, and so probably because
organizations like that, with a lot of power and money changed, things shifted, things became
much more negative, and then in the, again, in the later 90s, when you started to see a lot of
evangelism, first in agricultural biotechnology, then in forestry, and so in 2001 was a big year
here at Oregon State and Corvallis, we had evangelism, somebody came in and there in the middle
of the night, you know, in Corvallis, and cut through a wire fence and damage it at 1,000 trees.
It was at night, and you can't tell at 1,000, if you end, and you hear it from 1s that are,
and so most of them, they actually didn't hit what they wanted to, but you know, it was
indication of just the intensity of the issue that I think was in March, and then in June,
there was Arson, against the collaborative mind of the University of Washington, his building was
almost completely burned down, a collaborating industry, and Klatskin, I had a million dollars,
and farm equipment damage, so it really wrapped up, and it really got intense.
I was the chair of an international society for tree biotechnology,
we were having a meeting in Oxford in, I guess it was 1999, a couple years earlier, and the one,
the one field trial of the gentry in England was vandalized, the evening of our international
site to the conference, and so all these things told me that holy cow society is not with us,
and then Europe, in particular, which was sort of finally reacting against MontSanto, and bringing in,
you know, gentry engineers, soybeans, as animal feed into the country, and blockading them,
and all that, when these trees were damaged, outside of Oxford, and these trees were trees
that had, without going into the technical details, they were engineered to be easier to pulp,
being take less energy, less chemicals to produce the same amount of pulp. So it's something that
we all thought of science at the environmentalists were in love, and then we have strong support for it,
but no, the bigger narrative in society really dominated that. So when these trees were destroyed,
the science of what we were doing was irrelevant, and the storyline, the major media, the
Guardian and others was MontSanto, now they're wreak havoc in the food supply, and now they're
going to wreak havoc in our forests, and we are all like holy cow, you know, what are these guys
smoking? But you know, that's how big the social narrative is about gentry and engineering and GMOs.
The details of the science really don't matter much, and that's a hard thing to remember,
but anyway, so, you know, 1999, 2001, also in 2001, we had 9-11 in the United States,
and the government called Eco Terrorist, Terrorist, and they pursued them the same ways,
they pursued people who were bonding the World Trade Center, and so that kind of stuff stopped.
The guys who did this stuff in Oregon and Washington were mostly cotton, but in jail,
and Europe, they continued, in the US, it stopped. But that was, you know, a big marker that
things were just crazy at a hand. But society's reaction continued to ramp up after that,
and, you know, one of the conditions we have today is that a great piece in others who have already
against this stuff have created conditions, or a forest, industries, really can't usually have a
engineering career. Their own certification organizations don't allow it, even a research.
So, the field trials, the collaborative work I've done with industries years ago,
doesn't happen anymore, because our happens outside of the Northwest and very special conditions,
because the social conditions have become so hostile, you know, just like in organic food,
you can't have any GMO in a no matter what. Even though scientists will say,
well, there's good use as other, in addition to the ones that are questionable,
it's an all-or-nothing thing, and that's where society's at with forest who uses right now.
And one of the things I've done in my career is try to argue that we need research
to find out what other good use is what are the not-so-good use is how we can make,
and not-so-good use can make it good, you know, and, you know, that kind of, that's really not
gone anywhere, even though I've tried to sort of, what I would consider to have a more middle
or more reasonable science-based agenda, the environmental community, the marketing,
arm of it, in particular, feels like this is the way they have to be to get the consumers
to buy their products, to charge more for it, and maybe do the right thing on their view.
So, it's become a hostile world, I'm really, I'll be able to finish my career using this technology,
but by and large, in forestry around the world, the amount of interest in genetic engineering
is that that is really gone. It's not zero, but it's really gone way down. The social pushback
is, you know, been bigger than anybody, sort of imagine. So, how have you been able to navigate
that or how have you, and of course, to adapt their compromise? Yeah, you know, it's a reality,
and, you know, it's important to recognize it's sort of a 12-step thing, recognize what you can change,
and what you can. And so, you know, I've written a bunch of papers about how a lot of smarter
way would be to regulate what a smarter way to be to market it. I had a paper in science magazine
last year, I've been up to the published in the very best journals, putting forward ideas of
collaborating with lawyers and economists, you know, to get the social stuff right, you know, being
on a biologist. But, you know, there's a larger, larger forces, larger social economic forces,
you know, big companies profit from, you know, avoiding GMOs. They're not going to stop doing it,
you know, it's not just full of software as a huge, a profit margin to saying you're cleaner than
now, and I call it greenwashing, but it's everywhere in the marketplace. Now, I can't buy a little
for a breath that I want without a no GMO seal, even though I'd like to avoid it because I know
it's meaningless. So, that's, you know, it's a bigger thing. So, what do you do in that,
from my point of view, you know, we had at OSU, we had an outreach and biotechnology program,
mainly funded to the College of Act, probably funded through forestry, that I was the chair
of the director for about eight years. It was kind of a soft program. It used to be something
that was a hard program, an extension, and a set of got software over the years. But we did,
we had a website and we hosted 40 public lectures, we got amazing scientists,
all of the other coming up, talked to the public in Corvallis about all these issues.
So, that was one way that I thought I could sort of really help change society or make society smarter
about this. And I think it was super successful, but I think OSU, the College of Agriculture,
has sort of tired over this, and there's only so much science can do. And so, they've set
it back away, they don't want to alienate, they're more organic elements, they're not anti-GMO.
And so, most universities, not all of them, but some larger jarty have said,
this is bigger than we can deal with. Our state funds are being cut. We'd rather have somebody
who's breeding berries, then nobody breeding berries, and how they, somebody fighting this
way of anti-biotechnology, because it's very complicated. You know, if you do responsible
outreach about it, it's not just a raw, raw, raw, raw. Here's the trade-offs. Here's the pros and
the cons, and the centros. So, it's a complicated story. So, anyway, from my own point of view,
I've said of thought, wrote scientific papers, talked to regulators. I still get a 304 or
five talks a year about, I talked at the public library in Salem to the environmental educators
consortium of there a few weeks ago. So, I still do things occasionally, but the basic
I've said, you know, I could do research to advance the science and the technology.
And when society is ready, if they're ever ready, it'll be there. And so, that's right,
but 95% of my energies is doing the science. And it's hard, one thing, the conditions are
sufficiently adverse in both Europe and the United States for applied biotechnology and the public
sector, that it's very hard to go to a USDA or department of energy, grant pounds, and say,
I have an idea for a better genophangine or treat. We're going to treat this and ask, and then
they're going to say, well, it's a GMO, right? So, it's going to be really hard to get regulatory approval,
companies are going to have trouble growing it. So, we're not going to fund that. And that's
happened the last 15 years, it's very hard. But the one kind of funding can still get a little bit of
is, if you want to say, well, we need better safety technology. We need to not worry so much about
getting better trees, but getting safer trees. And so, that's really that little niche has allowed me
to set a continued doing research. I do want genetic containment and so forth. And so, that's one of
the ways I've been able to keep doing what I believe is interesting and important. Getting the
science done, testing it in the field, and me it's very important, not just that I do laboratory work,
because you need to go out into a real-the-real world, the most laboratory ideas don't actually
work, because the world is complicated. And so, I thought I have stuff out. I have 10 acres growing
in Kravales now that are testing ideas from the field, from the laboratory. And anyway,
but it's this safety orientation that's allowed me to keep productive, keep doing good science,
even though the social milieu is extremely adverse and funding is very hard to get.
So, the work on bio-safety and sterile nursery plants has almost been the survival strategy
in your point. Exactly, yeah. And it's survival, but it's also something I said, I'm interested in
and when I started that construction, started working on poppers, I said, we need to figure out
containment. And so, I'm still doing that. And luckily, that hasn't dried up. You know,
you know, it couldn't be time, but it hasn't so far. And I do work that is state-of-the-art.
It's competitive throughout science and throughout agriculture. So, these are the panel
that funds this. This is mainly USDA panel called biotechnology risk assessment that
that won the ARS thing that he just mentioned was a separate thing related to it. But that's
funding all of agriculture. So, all we have to be doing work on trees that is competitive with
the very best work in corn. And that's hard because they have a lot more money and there are a lot
more advanced genetics. But I'm proud that I've been able to do that. I can compete with those guys.
It's a science we do is just as good. If I didn't, if I didn't, that's not all I probably couldn't,
but I can do it in popular. Something else for your view that caught my was the project on
carbon sequestration using top opportunities. Yeah, about that. Yeah, well, you know,
you know, it's interesting. It's a very, if you decide you're going to grow trees seriously for some purpose.
I mean, they're going to have a dominant dedicated use. What nature gives you is okay,
and you can tweak it further, but often you want something very different. And so,
my people do ecological modeling started saying, well, you know, if we produce trees that
had more roots and less stem, which is contrary to what people do in forestry, they tend to want
the fastest growing tallest tree. And I said, no, maybe we don't want the tallest one. Maybe we want
the fastest one with lots of roots. And the roots will add to the carbon of the soil and decay
much slower than stem material would. Maybe maybe we could even make the roots so they decay more
slowly and enhance the amount of terpenides and phenolics, these compounds that's slowed down,
decomposition, so the carbon stays around on the soil longer. So it's those ideas that we could
change in the allocation between tops and bottoms and change the chemistry of roots that would
promote carbon sequestration. That was the idea. We also thought, if we had a tree that has more roots,
it'll survive great stresses. It'll wire remediate soils better. We also have a problem in
industry that sometimes you select the fastest growing trees and this has happened in the Northwest
with Poppers, they blow down. We get these giant windstorms every now and then and they just blow over.
And so, and that also we have an agriculture, the green revolution, which is not a biotech
GML thing, but it's a bunch of technologies starting in about the 1960s. The key one is a scientist
figured out that we don't want taller wheat, we don't want taller rice, when you just select
for productivity, everything gets taller. And then you have a storm, they blow over their lodge,
and you've probably seen this around Pendleton that happens occasionally. And then the crop
is lost at rocks, the quality is closed. So what the scientists did is they found a dwarfism
gene, semi dwarfism, that keeps the wheat instead of being in a way over your head and keeps it
about here. And most of the wheat we see around, or again, is like that. But that's a particular gene
brought in from an Asian variety that constrains you from getting tall. So it gets more roots,
so it gets more, more seeds on it, and it doesn't launch. So it was also that thinking that
you know, maybe we can sequester more carbon, have a tree that's more drought tolerant by remediates
better by having them be shorter. And I'm not talking about three feet tall, I'm just a tree.
So instead of a hundred feet, you might be sixty feet, whatever, between slow it down and change
the distribution and the quality of the biomass. And so that's what that project was about.
Trying to tweak these trees for these particular goals. And we were successful at it. We did,
and some of the genes we tested were genes from the green revolution in wheat. And because the
mechanisms are very fundamental, they work quite well. And so we were able to get shorter trees
with more roots. And but was anybody going to use them? No, because they're a GMO, and because
they are, it would change the industry. Industry doesn't work that we're breeding,
we're going to have to be radically different. We have to get a GMO probably into the breeding
program. Because one of the things you're doing is you're creating trees that are smaller,
who grow as fast while in nature, those trees die, right? Because they can't get light.
So you'd have to change the whole way you breed trees and evaluate them. And anyway, it would be
very disruptive to the industry. But with the GMO element of it, it was an on-starter. So we did the
work, it was successful. And there it is. The science is done. Does somebody ever want to pick it up?
You know, I don't know. But that's what that was about, the short of it. Yeah.
And that was a project that had an association with Sungram. Is that correct?
That's right. Yeah. That was a Department of Energy USDA funded. It was a couple of them.
The biggest funding we got was from the biofuels section of the Department of Energy.
That was a big, and then we had some supplementary funding from other places. We've also got
funding from the Sungram and a couple other places on trying to make a tree that would have some
valuable co-products. So one of the problems with growing bioenergy is that energy is cheap in the
world. Unless we tax fossil fuels really aggressively, which we're not, almost anywhere,
as aggressively as it probably should be, they're not competitive. So how do you make them more
competitive? One of the ways is to engineer in some product that is high value, a new biochemical
that would be have some other higher use in industry. So we've tried to get trees that produce
bioplastics, things that you can use, and we're already using the similar versions
from bacteria, these cops that decompose, that you can put in the compost. We tried to make the same
kind of thing in the palper trees, and we did it, but we couldn't make enough to make it economic.
So we really need a major engineering leap to make that work. And so we're just no funding for it,
but it's also a hard problem. But that's one of the Sungram projects that was about
trying to figure out how to make those biofuels. I mean, collaborating with companies that
were doing in a different crops, and it's a hard problem. We still, I thought a student who sort of
working on an element topic, but it would require a pretty serious effort. Yeah. Has any of your work
intersected with the cross-layer-related products at all? Only that the short answer is no. I was
at a conference. The Panko Foundation is as far as true foundation funded by this. I assume
rich guy who really wants to infuse advanced engineering technology of all kinds to make better
wood products, including the laminated products for Oregon and for the industry. You know, why
aren't we doing genetic engineering? He's looking at all the amazing things in engineering,
you know, in the traditional sense, why not genetic engineering? And I went to this conference
with other engineers, and I told him that it's the broader social element. And it's also that
the industry is not ready for it because we're still sort of in the neolithic breeding wise. And so it
would just be like trying to teach a baby to run before it's able to walk and just didn't make sense.
He didn't want to hear that, but that's the reality of it. You know, so it could be done. And you know,
if we, but before we did that, for example, if you're going to add the precision of genetic engineering
to try to get the fibers to set a be bonded in a way that would be better for CLT or glue better,
whatever it might be, the first thing you want to do is just homogenize the wood. So you know,
you, you, so as an engineer, you want to know what's going to be a certain thing. And then you can
tweak it right. And right now, in our forest, the variability in wood properties is incredible.
So you first want to be able to probably clone trees. And the problem with that is that it's
not affordable in the industry right now. So unless you get to that, that's again, you know,
a crawl walk before you run. We're not going to get there. So I also told in that the industry,
until we can get to those barriers, I'm not ready for it. And that's a matter of economics.
And probably also social acceptability. Would it be okay to have clone Douglass for all over the
landscape? I don't know. Well, with a serial club site, they probably hate the idea. So, you know,
so I just, but due to economics, plus concern, it's just not happening. Yeah. Tell me about the
Leopold Leadership Program. I got that with something fairly important to you. Yeah, that really is a,
I was a, that's a great thing. And it, you know, resonates today. So, Jane Looktanko, I know
as you understand this professor, you know, president of AAAA National Academy member, you know,
amazing scientist in person. She and some colleagues said, you know, scientists don't have the skills
and the network to communicate with the media and decision makers, like they need to, you know,
and her interest was in getting more environmental science and science in general,
into policy, you know, and most politicians don't have science backgrounds, almost none of them do.
And so you need to talk their language. You need to know, you know, how they have decisions
are made and you need to know how to talk to the media, you know, how to talk to science journalists,
non-science journalists. So, they, she created this program. It was funded by various foundations
over the years. It's still centered at Stanford, an organization at Stanford, it still goes on.
And they train cohorts of something like 20 or so leading environmental scientists, people sort of
in a make career, who you can see have been very successful and are going to make an impact and are called
to speak to the world, to change the world. Very much like who I was growing up and who I still
am. And so you apply, you say what you do, you know, your publication, my career, your passions,
your skills. And so I was one, I think I may be the only person who would call himself a biotechnology
in that program. It's mostly ecologists. A few lawyers involved, a couple of economists,
but pretty much very strongly environmental people, people not so much working on the technology
side of it. But anyway, this group has been going on now. I'm going to guess 20 years,
something like that, but they have these cohorts of scientists who come through and a lot of them
are now, you know, very well established in the field. And there's a network of them and they
communicate and they collaborate and they try to organize action or let us to the editor and
conferences. So, particularly now, with all the things going on on the chopper administration,
it's kind of been, you know, come back to life. And when they're really trying to do things and so
for. And so anyway, that's, I'm part of that organization and, you know, I love to see information
that's share about how to be more effective. What do you do now is a scientist? What's the
right thing to do? There's a discussion going on about whether it's good or bad to engage in the
March for Science next month. Is that politicizing science more? Making us more of a special
interest group versus, you know, arbiters of truth or are not, or we have to. And so that's an example
of how that network helps. People think distributed information and it's very nice. You know,
like I said, I'm a, I'm kind of an outsider in it. And I kind of feel like when it comes to GMO,
those in biotechnology and agriculture, probably the majority of them are a negative on it. You
know, and I'm kind of a lone wolf there in saying, this is powerful. We just have to use it right.
So, you know, so I'm, I'm a, I'm a housing that and it's important to me. But it's also a network of
environmental scientists that are mostly, I'm not interested in the kind of stuff that I do. So,
anyway, there it is. I'm not, I'm not super active in a bi name means probably because as I said,
it doesn't, it's kind of a little bit to the, to the left, whatever it is, where I'm at in terms of
using technology in the world. Can you talk a bit more about GMOs with respect to food? That's
obviously a big issue for people. Yeah, you know, I followed that pretty intense of a teacher
batter at OSU have been doing that at this outreach program. It's very hot and very political,
and, you know, I think one thing that's really clear is that it's, it's mostly not about the science.
I think the people who are very against GMOs want to make it about very dangerous
in adequately studied science. And I just think for them, that's a tool, a tactic. I think
the people in the know no better than that. So, but as you know, there's issues of intensive,
part of the biggest issue is industrial agriculture in general, you know, and it's incredible benefits
and incredible harms. You know, probably plowing is the most damaging thing we do the whole planet.
But it's not just industrial agriculture, the plows, it's organic agriculture and everybody else,
and they often do it more. So, you know, and then you have use of agricultural chemicals
which are an incredible energy saver and productivity enhancer, but they can be used with
they can harm things, you know, the racial car system, the science brain helps show that for DBT.
And so now we're in a whole different era than we were back then where things are intensively
regulated and monitored and many bad things have been taken off markets and, you know, at least in the
Western world and to get a chemical approved, you know, it takes, I think, hundreds of millions of
dollars of tests and studies and the labels that restrict its use and so forth. So, there's a lot of
safeguards built into the system we didn't have back in the old days, but it's a good enough.
Now, it's not going to be perfect. We're going to make some mistakes. So, how do you think about
chemicals used in agriculture and you have systems like the organic certification system that's a
we won't use any, except actually for quite a long list of exceptions if you read the details.
But, so that's another element and the major GMO crops now use chemicals directly or indirectly.
They use chemicals in the form or promoting herbicides by being herbicide resistant.
They use chemicals in the sense of isolating a pesticide from a bacterium and putting it into plants.
And this pesticide, this something called BT, is one that's widely used in our organic agriculture.
So, it's very, very, very safe. And I've spiced it into a plant when now it's supposed to be very unsafe.
So, you know, there's all, but anyway, but it involves things like chemicals and it involves
intensity, PA regulation. And the more you regulate doesn't mean that people feel better about it,
it means it actually shines a big spotlight on it. And so, it's just extremely messy, both from a society
and so, of course, the science continues to grow and innovate. So, there's new stuff all the time.
So, how much regulation just impedes public benefits, impedes economic development versus
protects the public and the environment. And getting that right is crucial. And, you know,
I'm by no means a supporter of the current presidential administration in the particular individual,
but the issue of how much regulation is too much is a really hard technical one. And the
sound bites you get and all of these media are generally misleading and wrong. But in the area of biotech
and I've written a lot, I think the regulations are totally out of control. There are some kinds of
biotech that should be intensively regulated. Probably more than we have now. Other kinds really
does. There's good record that there's no regulation needed at all. Zero. We have this thing called gene editing,
the new technology from modifying the natural DNA there to, for strange reasons, which is what
breeding does, but now we do it with science and precision. That's probably going to be regulated,
certainly in Europe, like it's taking the gene from the far away species. It's from my claim,
just crazy. This is the CRISPR technique. Yeah, this is the CRISPR technique. But that's kind of,
and that's a big source of controversy right now. The USDA put out a proposal to not regulate
some parts of that, which I think is innovative and forward-looking. I don't know what's going to happen
under the current administration. And Europe is a very likely good that way. Either way, the organic
people have already said on record they will not accept it. So, you know, it's just an ugly messy
area, frankly. And it's right with trade-offs. I just gave a talk last night to my own laboratory group.
There was a very good way for lately on the record of GMO crops in terms of pesticide use.
To use more, to use less, to use better kinds of chemicals. And the reality is it's a mixed bag.
We're doing all that depending on the crop and the time frame and it's just, that's the reality of it.
But we know there's also billions of benefits to the economy. We know there's also improved soil
as a result. So, what's the right answer? So, if you like sort of simple answers, this is not the
area for you. So, that's sort of, I try to, when I speak about a peachy batter, I try to give
students a sense of both the frustration and anger at this simple-minded social response,
no GMO labels. Organic certification. I'm cleaner and better than you. And the reason of that,
people go to organic now. So, boy, GMOs. Regulations are so intense that breeders like me,
I could be breeding populists for Oregon using GMO techniques, except that a cost amount of
$100 million to release one variety. Even with CRISPR, it's just like. On the other hand,
you know, we have companies overusing our designs and creating our desired resistant weeds.
So, it's just really complicated and difficult, you know. So, my own personal point of view is
don't throw out the 80 with a bathwater. You know, take some intelligent milling around. But that's
not where society is at in terms of marketing and labels. That's not where regulations tend to be.
The regulations reflect people's fears. Regulators like to say they're science-based,
nowhere are they really science-based, they try. They're always trying, but the political pressure is
incredible. In the U.S. and in Europe, to actually make a science-based decision and the
the activist groups work so hard to influence the science, to get their people on the boards
and to change the way decisions are made. So, again, you know, I used to be a member of Greenpeace
in the Arab club in Friends of the Earth and all these guys and now I wouldn't give them a dollar.
So, you know, that's where I started, right? And now I don't trust them. I give a lot of money to
certain of our net floor organizations like the Nature Conservancy that are really science-based,
but these guys are not. So, who's the good guys anymore? So, anyway, in the whole food, GMO,
food biotechnology, you get all that. The good guys are the bad guys, the bad guys, the good guys,
how do you decide? Yeah, I have a, I have a note here to ask you about the future of forests.
Yeah, right, because yeah, a big question, but yeah, and here in your target, it feels
to be like, a lot of what you're doing now, you're creating work that might be used in the future
in a different environment. Yeah, and I think that's right. Is it fair to assume you think that the
future forests might ensemble would depend upon genetic engineering? Well, you know, I've made
the argument, one thing you have in the world with climate change, with people traveling around the
world, with pests evolving, ever more fast. The stress is on forests or enormous. There's, you know,
various papers recording, you know, a hundred of introduced and new pests that are damaging
forests everywhere. It's incredible, difficult thing. And, you know, the main way we deal with that
is through bio-control, conventional breeding, but sometimes those don't work. And so one case,
you may know the story of the American Chestnut, I don't know if you're familiar with that, it's a
species that was a dominant species, much like Douglas Furrow around here, all over the East Coast,
entirely destroyed by an exotic fungus. And so that was a hundred years ago, and now people have
been working through conventional breeding and bio-control to the story, and so far, not much
luck. And so scientists in the State University of New York has found, he studied the mechanism
of disease, the pathogenesis, how it really works. And it's like other pathogens where he's found
that they produce this thing called an oxalic acid that actually is what kill statisticians,
it produces an oxalic acid, it kills the tissues, and the fungus acts as kind of a
saprophied, and just basically eats the dead tissue. And I said, well, if we can just get rid of
their oxalic acid or turn it way down, maybe we'll turn it from that pathogen into a saprophied.
It'll still be around, but it's not going to really damage trees. So we did, he's done that.
Kind of an amazing thing. He took a gene from wheat. In fact, put it into chestnut and
he's a peer-to-peer resistant. So there's a case where genetic engineering was important,
and it was able to very, very quickly do what breeding other techniques couldn't do. And so that's
kind of a well-known case, but then we have lots of other species that are sort of an earlier
stages of that same devastation. There's Emerald Ashbore, there's Hanlocke delgid, a few other
things around the world that are in that category, what looks really bad for the species.
So from my point of view, when you have a crisis like that, you want to use all of your tools.
And genetic engineering is definitely one. When you come in, you don't say, well, what genetic
variation, the tree species has is going to have to be good enough. You say, what are all the tools
I have? And if a guy at St. University of New York or elsewhere says, I think I understand how this
pathogen works. Let's take a gene and move it. Let's tweak a native gene. Maybe we have,
we do have some things that are somewhat similar and chestnut, but we need to edit it. We need
to do CRISPR to change it. And let's do it faster, because this is an emergency to get this out
and start testing it, right? We can't wait for 20 years of regulatory analysis of ecological approval.
But we can't do that. Can't do that today, because of the rules and the regulations and people's
phobias, and the inability of companies to see that they could ever use such a trade. So there's
almost no investment in that kind of technology. And to me, that makes no sense. That's just,
when you're, you know, the line between precaution and paranoia, precaution is sort of, you know,
taking intelligent measures to, you know, look before you leave, paranoia is being so afraid
and building an institutional system that's based on fear. And that's, I think that's where
our app, which you know, it, it makes no sense. So, you know, anyway, so I think it could be a powerful
technology for the future. All trees could be semi-dorth in a future time if people were to actually
allow that to happen, and maybe they'd be more productive and more stress resistant, but we're not
going to know in my lifetime if that's sure or not. So, you know, you know, so I think this
powerful things we could do that, I think the uses would be selected. These really more
agree just cases that I mentioned, because conventional breeding is very powerful, and there's
essentially no limit to it. You could take a species from anywhere around the world and move
it here to Oregon and if it works, you know, it's fine. So that's radical genetic engineering,
and we can do that without any constraints, but if you tweak a gene, there's these huge constraints
in issues. So why mess with tweaking genes when you can do that other stuff? So, you know, we sort of
paint that ourselves into this corner if you want them, you know, a bit. So, we graduate students
have soon come to your lab because they're attracted by your work and want to pursue similar
topics. What do you tell them? I mean, it sounds to me like, yeah, you hit a time period of
yeah, of cultural history, I suppose, where you could have the work that you did,
right? But that window is closed. Well, I tell them, you know, I tell them, if you think you're going
to graduate and get a job in the forest industry, doing biotechnology, the job opportunities are
extremely small. So, I tell them you have to be competitive with any agricultural biotechnologist.
You need to be able to get a job at one of those companies or at the USDA that's still doing
some of this, particularly for serious diseases. And you need to have what I call a bioinformatics
training. Meaning that, you know, putting the GML thing aside, you need to be able to do a state
of your computational biology, which doesn't involve DMOs because that's the on trade to where
most jobs are in, you know, in the broad area of biotech science. So, you know, but otherwise, a lot
of them come to me because they're motivated by the things we're talking about. They want to see
the world change because they see how powerful genetic engineering is. They see all of this
information out there including from the good guys. And they're, they're, they're, they're angry
on their passionate. So, you know, I tell them, you know, I just wind open. This is the reality.
So, that's what they say. But, but again, it's really critical. They do state-of-the-art work.
It just happens to be on trees. And then, they're going to post doc and now be able to move into
other areas. A couple of concluding questions that I'm interested in your perspective on
change in the college of forestry that changes very visible to everybody, right? No,
it's as if they call work PV always. Yeah. But tell me how the college has changed and moved
in different directions and the years of your association. Yeah, you know, I think we have a great
leader and, you know, Dean Thomas Mann is very visionary who really wants to move the college ahead
very powerfully he wants to sort of move into the environmental mainstream if he can. He's trying
to build much better bridges with environmental organizations than we've had historically.
He wants to reduce the polarization we've had amongst the more in pro-industry and the pro-environment
folks. And I think that's happening over time successfully. He wants to move into the
advanced, you know, laminated technologies and this new building that's, you know, a big part
of the money and the push to do that kind of thing. I think that's really positive.
Colleges also now in different parts of campus and that's heard sort of a sense of unity
that we have. So, you know, I think, I think he's trying to set us on the right path and do the
right thing and I hope he can bring his vision through the completion, but I think that's set
of unknown right now. What kind of impact do you think the new forestry complex might have on the
college? Well, you know, I think new buildings have discussed in this with various colleagues.
You know, it's obviously a big cost. But, you know, the environment you live and work in matters,
it matters to how you feel, how you interact with people. I'm in Richards and Hall, which was
about 15 or 19 years old, but it was designed with lots of light, lots of wood and it's brought
people together. It's been, you know, had its own little design flaws. We found out, expect that
keeping out things like rain. You know, it's a really beautiful environment. And so I think he wants
to take back to another level and create really a sense of greenness and collaboration and, you know,
an innovation that I think a new building helps to motivate. So, you know, I like the idea and I,
you know, I think there was criticism about whether it was green enough and how green you need to
be to tear down an existing functional building, but also quite old fashioned and not a great
collaborative space at all. Very much in the old model of people basically in file cabinets.
So, you know, I think I think there's not a lot to try to be green while also making it
something you can sell to donors because donors don't want to invest in, you know, changing the
siding and existing building if they want to invest in an vision. And so, I think you didn't
really have a choice but to create a new building. So, you know, I'm hoping that, you know, that
the dean comes back and the building is as beautiful and as functional as you hope it will be
helps, you know, bring us to another level. So, but right now, I think we're in this kind of precarious
place where you're a two-out, I'm happy in that building. And all building projects I know of,
it costs more than you think. And then you have to make difficult decisions as you go and
does it actually do everything you thought you were going to do with it. So, I think there's those
risks as well, but I'm hoping. Yeah. In my last question, a few, this is a SESCO Centennial
project and then I'm interested in your point of view on the university as it looks towards its
150th birthday, where do you think I'll see this position right now? Yeah, I really felt really
fortunate to be part of this institution for the 30th and going on that 30th year that I've been here.
I've got the leadership that I've had in the college of fire. She's been excellent.
John Barr and Ed Ray, I think have been, you know, inspiring and responsible leaders.
I have not gotten involved in administration significantly. So, like, every other type of
member, I know I wonder if we are investing far too much given our limited state budgets in
administrators, they just seem to be everywhere. So, I wonder whether every administrator is
really needed and what they're doing, what their impact is. But in general, I like the ethics
and the structure of the place and I'm proud to be a part of it. So, you know, I like the emphasis
that we have on equity and diversity here and I think that's really important. You know, Oregon
is a very white place and it's a white place or institutional reasons. In my opinion, those need
to be corrected and addressed. So, I'm proud that we're doing that pretty actively. We're doing
it pretty actively in forestry as well. So, I think that's the right thing to do. So, you know,
in general, I feel good about it. I would love to see more of the administration explain
who they are, what they do, and how cost effective they are. And they don't seem to feel they
need to do it. So, I don't think that's right. So, in that regard, you know, I would love a little
bit more of a business sense of explaining to faculty how they're making smart decisions and what
the administrative decisions that they make really cost as compared to, you know, I don't know
could we have 10% less administration, 10% or 50% more faculty members doing innovative
research and teaching. You know, I just, those tradeoffs, I don't understand them. And I don't
know anybody does because I don't think administrators feel the need to explain them to, to
play the ins life meat. And I know I don't like that. So, anyway, but so, in general, very positive,
but you know, with some sense that maybe we have some runaway administrative investments. And
I think that's a common problem in higher education, you know, so as far as I understand it. So,
how do you rate that in? How do you at least understand it and decide if you agree with it or not?
Yeah, certainly not the first time I've heard that. Yeah, but in short, I mean, I feel privileged
to have been here. The community has been an extraordinary place for me to live and raise my
children. And, you know, as when I go back to my Yale reunions and those folks are all over the world
and they say, hey, you know, you travel everywhere. Where would be your ideal place to live?
I always say, I'm living there. I travel the world too and this is a incredible place today.
So, that's a good note to stop on. Thank you very much. So, you really appreciate this.